[Musique]
nous allons parler d'une disparition qui
nous touche particulièrement au figaro
celle de jean d'ormesson jean d'ormesson
qui fut directeur du journal et dont il
était resté lamy on s'intéressera aussi
à ses médiocres résultats des écoliers
français en lecture des élèves qui sont
parmi les plus mauvais dans les pays
européens tester alors à qui la faute
aux méthodes de lecture ou maître
d'école chacun a son avis sur le sujet
nous débattrons également d'une autre
question sensible les crèches de noël
laurent wauquiez exposé des santons à
lyon au conseil régional
est ce un pied-de-nez au conseil d'état
qui interdit les crèches dans les lieux
publics on verra tout cela
et enfin je me propose de nous
intéresser à ce café de cimentier
lafarge en syrie le groupe a financé le
terrorisme soupçonne les juges
comment un tel scandale at il pu durer
deux ans on peut s'interroger
et surtout n'hésitez pas vous
internautes à vous prononcer sur ces
thèmes les questions vous sont posées
via twitter hashtag figaro live
#primaires but alors vous n'avez plus
qu'à cliquer des présentations brève
avant d'entrer tout de suite dans le vif
du sujet pour jean marc four vous êtes
directeur de la rédaction de france
inter
vous nous direz aussi vos souvenirs de
jean d'ormesson lors d'interviews à
france inter
bonjour fredrik sinclair a un jour vous
êtes analyste politique vous avez été
conseiller en communication de
conseiller de dominique de villepin à
matignon
et vous savez je crois une anecdote à
nous raconter aussi sur jean d'ormesson
vaujour ivan rioufol vous êtes l'auteur
d'un très attendu bloc note hebdomadaire
dans le figaro et éditorialiste et ses
iris et vous aviez accompagné
l'académicien au château de combourg
enfin bon joueur pas tendre et rédacteur
en chef du service économie france du
figaro et vous nous raconterez peut-être
la venue de jean d'ormesson lorsqu'il
était venu il ya un peu plus d'un an à
la conférence de rédaction du journal
alors je vous rappelle que vous pouvez
participer à cette émission via twitter
juste avant de vous donner la parole à
tous les cas je vous propose de regarder
un extrait des rencontres
du figaro était invité jean d'ormesson
c'était le 7 mai dernier salle gaveau ce
n'est pas forcément une parole très
profonde très académique mais elle
montre bien ce jean d'ormesson qui se
moquaient de lui même de ses talents de
séducteur équivoque et sans s'appesantir
le temps qui passe
ce que j'ai entendu le plus dans ma vie
c'est des jeunes filles ravissantes qui
arrivent et qui disait ma mère vous
alliez ralliement et ensuite il ya 30
ans
ça change et ça a été ma grand mère vous
avez et je vous assure que je raconte
cette histoire chez gallimard
j'étais en train de signer kalima et je
raconte cette histoire et la porte
s'ouvre et aux ravissantes jeunes
stagiaires le 18
je crois que je m'en rappelle comme en
sable c'était un discret elle s'appelle
un très joli notionnels ou ségolène 2006
et rougissant jusqu'au bout
elle me dit monsieur je crois que vous
êtes un ami de mon argent mais c'est
tout l'humour et l'autodérision en même
temps durs d'ormesson
il vole vous aviez effectivement reçues
lors d'un prix littéraire remis au
château de combourg jean d'ormesson
racontez-nous un tout petit peu je
n'étais pas du tout intime de jean
d'ormesson met effectivement en 2001 je
l'avais accompagné parce que j'étais
jury n'a prix littéraire on devait lui
remettre le prix combourg au château de
combourg là où a vécu chateaubriand
enfants et lui était un miroir de
châteaubriant ce qu'il est il est
naturellement sa vie a été projeté un
petit peu sur celle de châteaubriant et
on s'était aperçu je m'étais aperçu avec
stupéfaction qu'il n'avait jamais mis
les pieds à combourg de sa vie alors que
c'est en ille et vilaine c'est pas très
loin et qu'il découvrait là les
l'endroit les endroits qui font les
premières pages des mémoires
d'outre-tombe et donc il avait demandé à
voir actuellement la chambre de
chateaubriand qui est au bout
au d'un donjon et surtout il avait
demandé à ce qu'on lui désigne quel
était le coin de la fenêtre dans lequel
chateaubriand qui a 11 ans décrit sa
première sa première histoire érotique
si je puis dire par après avoir effleuré
le sein d'une jeune femme par
inadvertance et donc montré là là là
maître des céans qui est une descendante
de châteaubriant je vais montrer où la
fenêtre ou en effet parce que rien n'a
bougé et enfin quasiment pas sauf un
petit aménagement intérieur et il avait
pu voir également les quelques
manuscrits de châteaubriant ce que manu
chateaubriand brûler ses manuscrits sont
très rares et il y en a encore un peu
qu'ils sont là et c'est là la comtesse
de la tour du pin qui lui est acquis
bruits qui met ça bien en sécurité dans
ce château plat voilà jean-marc vous
l'avez reçu à france inter à plusieurs
reprises par france inter de nombreuses
reprises en ce qui me concerne deux fois
interviewé deux fois mais bon voilà
comme j'allais dire comme les modestes
scribouillard des journalistes que nous
sommes bons en interview plein de gens
vous voyez et et les interviews se
succèdent de certaines plus
intéressantes que d'autres et jean
d'ormesson il y avait des choses qui
frappait enfin qui moi m'avait frappé
premièrement c'est le regard c'est à
dire que vous l'interviewer il vous
regardait comme ça a droit dans les yeux
il captait votre regard et puis bouger
plus il vraiment il vous parle est à
vous c'est la deuxième chose qui m'avait
frappé c'est qu'il veut il fait partie
de cette poignée de personnes avec
lesquelles l'interview n'était pas
quelque chose de standardiser c'est à
dire que vous savez il ya des il ya des
gens des professionnels devant le
spectacle mediterra il enchaîne les
interviews comme d'autres passent leurs
articles à la caisse du supermarché quoi
c'est tout plus du tout les mêmes etc
mais bien avec lui non vas-y vous aviez
quelques achats souvenir du même genre
c'est mastroianni bahamas triste et
pareil en fait il vous alliez avoir
quelque chose il le dos n'est qu'à vous
puis après il allait voir quelqu'un
d'autre il allait de données qu'à
l'autre aussi parce qu'en fait il
s'intéressait aussi à vous dont kiel en
fait c'était un échange avec vous ce
n'était pas juste une interview de plus
c'était un échange avec la personne
qu'il interviewait c'est ça qui moi
m'avait tout à fait saisi
mais eric sinclair petit mot de votre
expérience de jean d'ormesson ou échange
pour pour mettre en contexte jean
d'ormesson donc moi je suis un garçon un
enfant de la province j'ai grandi dans
l'est dans les montagnes de
l'arrière-pays niçois et songe à tous
genres jean d'ormesson cc pour moi le
l'archétype de l'intellectuel parisien
qui que je découvre finalement assez
tard par l'intermédiaire de raymond aron
donc on est vraiment dans le figaro le
pilier intellectuelle du figaro raymond
aron dont je lis les mémoires autour de
mes 20 ans et j'ai une image honnêtement
il faut quand même le dire de jean
d'ormesson dépeint par raymond aron qui
n'est pas exceptionnel au même moment je
lis cette biographie sentimentale qui
l'écrit de chateaubriand qui fait que je
tombe amoureux de madame de récamier et
que je vois ce chateaubriand flamboyant
comme robert de montesquiou ouvriers
peint par boldini la exceptionnel dont
quelque part là l'image de jean
d'ormesson devient quelques plus
substantiel plus + lustré plus belle je
commence à découvrir
l'aristocrate je me dis bon bah ce
monsieur là quand même c'est c'est une
figure un monument en france et puis par
hasard alors que un soleil magnifique
un beau jour de mois de mai je me
trouvais sur la place saint sulpice à
paris j'avais finalement déménagé
quitter mais mes montagnes et qui je
vois ce beau georges jean d'ormesson et
ses magnifiques yeux bleus
alors je me dis c'est l'occasion je
cours vers lui pour le rencontrer pour
le saluer et j'ai pas eu le temps
d'aligner deux phrases il s'est carapaté
ima il m'a glissé dans les doigts plus
personne rien donc jean d'ormesson reste
pour moi l'homme mystérieux alors marc
landré on avait une houle l'occasion
parce que vous avez partagé cette même
toujours dans le sens était venu à la
conférence de rédaction du figaro
c'était en juin 2016 de mémoire et ce
qui était très frappant c'est qu'il
était fou moi ce que je le souvenir que
j'en ai c'est qu'il était à la fois
évidemment plutôt à l'aise mais en étant
presque timide et soucieux de bien faire
parce qu'il avait pendant quelques
instants mener la conférence de
rédaction quels souvenirs vous en a
et vous c'était un grand moment on a des
digues des grands hommes comme ça on n'a
pas l'occasion de rencontrer tous les
jours et c'est effectivement il y avait
le côté symbolique de l'homme qui
revenait là où il avait dirigé plus de
40 ans le figaro pour mener une
conférence de rédaction à une époque et
selon des méthodes qui avait
radicalement changé
je pense que le figaro n'est plus ce
qu'il était dans les années 70 sur la
ligne notamment
et sur le fond enfin sur la méthode sur
la forme il n'y a plus rien à voir et on
avait vu ce décalage effectivement
journée c'est jean d'ormesson qui était
resté avec c'est normalement et ses
vieux réflexes ont commencé par le web
par la vidéo par le premium il était
paumé il était paumé et d'ailleurs je
trouve que on s'est rendu compte qu'il a
eu des moments d'absence pendant cette
cette conférence de rédaction
il y avait de la vivacité d'esprit un
certain moment effectivement retrouvé le
ti coq il a été ou qu'il était encore
alors et d'autres moments on sentait
qu'ils avaient dit moment donné toujours
cette volonté effectivement de d'être le
plus à l'aise possible avec avec les
gens qui l'entouraient de les mettre à
l'aise même weeping simplicité
déroutante déroutante ali un homme qui
était qui était peut-être quitter la
halle qui était heureux d'être là et
dans wii il était là parce qu'il y avait
un documentaire de produits tournés par
laurent delahousse qui était dans les
couloirs pour un jour un destin de
mémoire c'est un film qui va sortir en
salles normalement et mais il était très
simple et très heureux d'être là et avec
une émotion qui était palpable et qui se
ressentait et finalement qui était aussi
communicative qui était ressentie par
l'ensemble de la table suspendue comme
ça je vous rappelle que vous pouvez
participer à cette émission via twitter
#skype hashtag point de vue dites nous
ce que vous évoque jean d'ormesson
apparemment on vous proposait au soin
ses livres ses chroniques ou ses
passages à la télévision ce sont ces
passages à la télévision qui retiennent
le plus votre attention
alors évidemment il ya eu beaucoup de
réactions politiques et autres
finalement il vend il avait bien des
facettes jean d'ormesson mais c'était on
dit un homme de droite mais le meilleur
ami de la gauche
c'était l'écrivain l'académicien
qu'est-ce que vous là dessus sur ces
vous retenez moi ce que je retiens le
plus c'est d'ailleurs ce qui est très
émouvant dans cette danse est témoin
collectif que procure sa disparition
c'est qu'il est le symbole de cette
france que l'on craint que l'on dit
avoir disparu de cette france post
littéraire postes culturels
non on se rend compte que la france est
un vieux pays littéraire vous savez il y
avait un million de personnes et plus à
l'enterrement de victor hugo en 1885 et
donc et à la france continue alors
naturellement ce n'est pas du tout je
met pas du tout en parallèle les deux
les deux personnages victor hugo
naturellement le et est bien supérieur à
lui littérairement mais on retrouve
quand même dansé témoin là quelque chose
qui est très profond dans l'âme
française et qui rend hommage dans le
fond a d'ailleurs le président de
république l'a très bien dit à l'esprit
français et l'esprit français se
caractérise très bien par ses
caractéristiques à lui c'est à dire
cette gaieté cette désinvolture
apparente ces mots d'esprit cette
impertinence et ans mais en même temps
cette grande vivacité cette grande
l'utilité mais surtout cette grande
liberté de parole que l'on a plutôt
tendance et oublier aujourd'hui je pense
que les français se reconnaissent là
dedans et ce n'est pas tellement de la
nostalgie c'est aussi me semble le team
là je vais peut-être un peu plus loin
dans le raisonnement c'est peut-être
aussi une manière de vouloir protéger
précisément ce qui a fait la france
depuis l'ancien régime parce que lui
c'est quand même un petit peu le
témoignage de ce qu'était la france
d'ancien régime
une émotion des français - c'est jean
marc four suis assez d'accord je pense
qu'il ya quelque chose de très français
et de deux
les français voyaient watts en lui
quelque chose
il aimerait penser que c'est la france
est compris dans l'aspect vous dis
désinvolture apparente je pense que
l'adjectif est aussi important que le
mot c'est à dire qu'il y avait
certainement chez jean d'ormesson moi je
n'avais pas de connaissance intime de
jean d'ormesson mai mais quelque chose
de l'ordre de la façade au site cnet
cette désinvolture cette gaieté enfin
comme souvent d'ailleurs j'ai des
épicuriens pour faire pour faire bref
en réalité derrière ya beaucoup de
profondeur et l'ours qui est très très
intéressant c'est de voir les aussi des
réactions de deux personnes qui
n'étaient pas de son camp politique pour
faire simple quand on regarde et ce
qu'en dit quelqu'un comme jean luc
mélenchon jean luc mélenchon qui dit je
crois nous n'étions pas d'accord mais
c'était toujours un plaisir et ça alors
déjà qu'en tant que jean luc mélenchon
en dire du bien de quel car déjà ça
j'ai quand même pas banal mais l'art de
la part de la conversion et c'est assez
vrai c'est à dire que on voit bien que
même chez les gens qui n'étaient pas
d'accord avec lui au moins il y avait ce
plaisir d'échanger de discuter de la
dialectique etc et ça c'est très
professionnel
un de droite qui était effectivement
plutôt apprécié par la gauche qui avait
été le dernier jour de mitterrand à
l'élysée le voir le matin même avion que
la connexion intellectuelle avec
françois mitterrand est évidente au
niveau littéraire et une passion
réciproque pour les lettres
ensuite il y a chez jean d'ormesson je
l'évoqué tout à l'heure rapidement c'est
ce caractère paris stockera tic dans le
meilleur sens du terme cercle
effectivement il
ligne et effectivement il y a mais c'est
une aristocratie de la pensée une
élégance je pense que que qui rappelle
qui rappelle la france le bel esprit
était incarnée par par jean d'ormesson
il ya eu des pour moi je le vois comme
un trait d'union entre mauriac et aaron
qui étaient deux immenses figure l'une
littéraire l'autre intellectuelle de
cette deuxième partie du xxème siècle et
jean d'ormesson et celui qui mondain est
capable de tenir la main à l'un et à
l'autre
un dernier mot peut-être marc-andré puis
ensuite on va écouter alexis brézet vous
aviez quelque chose à ajouter tout à
l'heure bref vous peut-être que ça vous
a échappé de musique disco d'études la
même remarque c'est que effectivement
jean luc mélenchon mais c'était deux ces
deux intellectuels qui ce qui aimait
discuter ensemble
il dit beaucoup de mal des gens qui sont
vivants midi peu de mal des gens qui
sont morts donc il aurait été
particulièrement malvenue dans le
concert de louanges actuelle que
jean-marc que jean-luc large sur les
dangers de la mission s'arrête aux
portes de l'enfer ici si jolie parade
estime pour nathalie saint cricq au
pouvoir des gens du service public de
l'audiovisuel puis reposant dans la
maison il en avait effectivement parce
que c'était deux intellectuels
voilà deux grandes figures lithaire
palita jamais entre deux personnes qui
savent français qui aimait discuter
ensemble et qu'ils étaient les mamies
vaut peut-être peut-être peut-être on va
y rester et rod et alexis brézet
directeur des rédactions du figaro qui
raconte un peu comment s'était passée la
conférence de rédaction à laquelle
avaient assisté gendarmes sont il ya un
an et donc on évoquait avec marc landré
tout à l'heure on écoute gens arrivent
dans cet immense talent qui est qui et
la newsroom et là tout à coup les nuées
de jeunes gens deux jeunes filles et
jeunes femmes qui arrivent et qui ce jeu
qui l'entourent qui se mettent autour de
lui qui avant voilà madame à la volée il
a passé la matinée à faire des selphy
avec avec tous et j'adore il était
emballé voilà
ils étaient très contents et c'était
très sympa cette phase de passage de
témoin de transmission entre cette jeune
génération et et puisque jean d'ormesson
qui kiss et c'est quand même frappant ce
jusqu'à la fin de sa vie peut être de
plus en plus plus il avançait dans sa
vie un quart des quelque chose pour la
jeunesse c'est très très étonnant parce
qu'il avait cette jeunesse en lui qui
dès que la jeunesse se reconnaissaient
en lui
vous êtes nombreux à nous faire part
aussi de vos commentaires evelyne salue
un grand homme christian un esprit
optimiste lumineux nous quitte ou l'épée
de l'académicien servait la liberté une
vie extraordinaire
le droit le droitiste avec le départ le
droit si c'est le nom de notre
internaute
avec le départ de jean d'ormesson c'est
un peu de rareté qui s'en est allé et
josh athanase d'ormesson ou d'ormesson
c'est vrai que c'est une question je
crois que c'est d'ormesson pour répondre
à cette question mais je ne sais pas si
vous avez des je ne peux john ford
on va passer à notre deuxième thème il
s'agit de la lecture et c'est une
nouvelle qui n'auraient pas fait plaisir
à jean d'ormesson
les petits français sont mauvais en
lecture leur note à peine la moyenne et
le résultat sont en baisse
tel est le résultat d'une enquête
internationale menée dans 50 pays auprès
d'élèves de 9 à 10 ans c'est à dire le
niveau de cm1 le ministre de l'éducation
a réagi à ces piètres performances il
préconise une dictée quotidienne alors
internautes prononcez vous sur cette
mesure via twitter et on écoute jean
michel blanquer
la france se situe à l'antépénultième
place des 24 pays de l'union européenne
qui ont participé à alan qui s'est donc
des résultats préoccupants
c'est donc très important d'avoir une
grammaire et un vocabulaire développer
la grammaire c'est la grammaire de
phrases qui doit retrouver sa pratique
régulière dans l'enseignement primaire
le vocabulaire c'est la richesse du
vocabulaire l'orthographe c'est le
résultat de cela avec la dictée la
dictée quotidienne jean marc four une
dictée quotidienne pour répondre à cette
naufrage en lecture en à dire c'est
peut-être un peu court c'est vrai c'est
sans doute pas suffisant ça c'est
certain et ce qui est certain aussi
c'est que la taille de la boule de neige
dépendent
une quantité de neige qui avaient dans
l'appentis m'explique oui le niveau en
cm1 dépend de ce que vous avez fait
avant est d'ailleurs un peu la position
de jean michel blanquer r cela veut dire
que là où l'effort doit être porté ses
hauts niveaux du cp et même probablement
avant c'est-à-dire en maternelle et
d'ailleurs c'est l'une il ya eu c'est la
deuxième étude en fait puisqu'il ya eu
l'étude pisa il ya quelques temps qu'ils
n'ont les conclusions étaient peu ou
prou les mêmes s'étaient pas
spécifiquement sur la lecture mais
c'était plus générale et ça ça à
parvenait à peu près aux mêmes
conclusions
est ce que ce que dit l'étude pisa entre
autres c'est que s'ajoutent aux c'est à
dire que c'est vraiment des des
enseignements des tout petits que se
nouent ceux qui derrière va permettre
que in fine et or en cm1 cm2 rentrée
collège
vous avez des gens qui ont c'est pour
lesquels c'est déjà trop tard
donc il faut s'en préoccuper très tôt
par iphone vous allez accusés qui les
profs a accusé les profs certainement
pas les profs mais accusée en tout cas
l'éducation nationale oui parce que
c'est toi un bien beau système éducatif
que d'apprendre à lire à compter à
écrire or on se rend compte et c'est
effarant d'ailleurs de voir à quel point
cette décadence et provoquent ces genres
de
le résultat c'est naturellement alors
c'est facile à dire comme ça mais il y a
des responsabilités partagées mais je
pense quand même que le pédagogie de ce
qu'on appelait le pédagogisme c'est à
dire 7 7 v à cette vision qui voulait
mettre l'élève au centre d'études de la
structure que l'élève que mal et ballet
lui-même faire fait renaître son propre
savoir et tout ça c'était naturellement
des bêtises il y a eu une grande
indifférence porté à cela et on a il ya
même eu des livres qui ont été écrits
pour soutenir que le niveau montait le
niveau monte en nous at on dit à un
moment donné donc c'était cette école
des idéologues s'effondre mais ça
ce constat est fait depuis très
longtemps cela fait des années
simplement on convoi plaît cela continue
a fait à produire ces désastres et on
peut se réjouir en effet que l'on est
aujourd'hui enfin un ministre de
l'éducation qui qui parle qui se
confronte à ses réalités d'un et qui
parle avec bon sens et le bon sens en
l'occurrence je lui laisse les les les
solutions parce qu'elles ne sont pas
dans les compétences que je pense qu'en
effet pour une certaine classe de des
sites et enfin des clés des cités
difficiles de diviser par 2 de faire des
classes à 12 élèves dans les cpe etc me
paraît être une bonne chose et mais je
pense qu'il faut aussi et de plus en
plus mobilisés les familles à la lecture
la borne mobiliser les familles et à la
confiance qu'elles peuvent apporter à
l'école ce qui n'est pas toujours le cas
dans les dents les familles nouvelles de
l'issue de de l'immigration nouvelle et
puis surtout faire en sorte que la
lecture redeviennent quelque chose on
parlait de d'ormesson et de cette france
qui est une vieille nation littéraire il
est alors maison en effet aurait été
bouleversée d'apprendre que aujourd'hui
les jeunes ne lis plus mais ça ce n'est
pas simplement la france qui est en
cause bien entendu mais il faut
aujourd'hui que la france puisse renouer
avec ses racines et ses racines elle
passe notamment par la re découverte du
livre de la lecture
et ça ça peut être le rôle de l'école me
semble-t-il on avait beaucoup glosé sur
la princesse de clèves c'est une belle
bêtise qu'il avait dit sinclair un mot
là-dessus
disons que c'est c'est ça montre
simplement la continuité dans la
conception qu'on entretient du rôle de
l'école de une sorte de déculturation il
y a
il y à un utilitarisme généralisée qui
s'est développée durant tout le 20e
siècle qui a conduit les responsables
politiques et j'allais dire peut-être
même les élites dans le sens que plus
large du terme à faire de l'école un
objet utile aujourd'hui l'école ne sert
plus à émanciper l'individu et à lui
fournir une culture dans le sens le plus
noble du terme et sert à avoir un job
donc forcément quand on fabrique de
l'élève qui est destiné à avoir un job
on le met en connexion avec les
différents aspects les plus utiles pour
de la société marée basse il évince y
ranger vos cv ils font quoi eh ben ce
qu'on fait c'est qu'on dit que puisque
demain il faudra absolument être
connectés et bien des cp on va commencer
à réfléchir aux manières de connecter
l'enfant aux langues étrangères aux
cultures étrangères à l'internet et donc
finalement on s'éloigne de ce qui a
constitué pendant des décennies le socle
fondamental c'est à dire je veux
acquérir demain à savoir il faut que je
puisse aujourd'hui savoir lire
correctement pour aller le chercher une
autonomie parce que c'est ça finalement
que montre aussi lé l'étude
c'est qu'il ya une incapacité à
interpréter les données donc là la
réflexion des enfants de france est
vraiment en recul à côté de ça j'aurais
tendance à dire juste pour terminer
qu'il faut aussi qu'on prenne en compte
la la nature multiculturelle aujourd'hui
de notre société qui forcément à mon
avis intervient d'une façon ou d'une
autre quand les parents ne parlent pas
la langue c'est beaucoup plus difficile
pour un enfant qui entrent au cp
d'apprendre à lire en 50 pour un enfant
qui a quitté baigne au quotidien dans
l'enfance de marque c'est aussi binaire
que ça on fabrique le soient c'est des
citoyens cultivés ou des chômeurs n'ont
pas forcément ça c'est comme un petit
peu plus
jean jacques goldman gris clair les
français c'est pas binaire c'est pas
blanc noir je suis fan de batman c'est
pour ça que me permets de citer non mais
je crois que c'est surtout chaque
génération a tendance de dire tendance
est à dire de la prochaine qu'elle est
inculte ou en tout cas qu'elle n'a pas
les mêmes bases qu'elle n'a pas les
mêmes compétences je pense que nos
parents disaient ça de nous et nous on
dit ça on dit ça nos enfants peut-être
que ce qui est accentué aujourd'hui
parce qu'effectivement le niveau baisse
de génération en génération c'est ça
c'est ça c'est à dire que c'est la grève
dans tous les pays
c'est vrai dans tous les pays mais
particulièrement en france et être
content d'un nouveau plus bas les culés
je vivais jeu vidéo sortent mieux
malgré tout alors qu'ils assuraient leur
apprentissage est différent oui voilà
donc même c'est dans cette attente et
servir oui bien moi j'ai deux les
réformes quand je les vois rédigé
effectivement et je suis d'accord c'est
pas forcément la dictée quotidienne qui
changera fondamentalement les choses
j'ai quand on écrit un sms est compliqué
toi déliquescent fonctionner mais ce que
disent ses études c'est bien payé en
cela qu avant pis ça c'est là je vais
prendre un sociologue qui n'est pas du
tout le figaro en fait raymond aron mais
c'est presque aurait pu dire un gros
dieu c'est à dire que c'est la france
est l'un des pays où le déterminisme
social et le plus bien pèse le plus dans
les résultats éducatifs
c'est à dire qu'en fait ce que ce qui se
joue beaucoup c'est pas seulement dans
le moment où on est à l'école en cours
ces 6e qui se joue en dehors dans le
milieu familial effectivement dans le
milieu social et que là il ya un poids
on va dire d'aller je fais cours de la
classe sociale de l'environnement qui
est beaucoup plus fort en france que
dans les autres pays c'est ce que disent
et des conclusions de notamment pisa
c'est ce qu'il disait donc il ya
forcément il ya du rejet en garde
l'office de le terrain pour le constater
et en libérant le comprend assez bien
c'est vrai quand vous avez aujourd'hui
des cités qui se ghettoïse qui ce qui se
ramasse sur elle même et bien vous avez
entre les familles n'ont plus envie de
s'identifier à une culture et la culture
patins durement par la lecture ne peut
pas isoler le sujet de l'apprentissage
de la lecture sans l'on peut pas le
sortir du paysage global
bien sûr que non bien sûr nous avons
chantal qui estime que la dictée
quotidienne c'est peut-être une bonne
idée mais elle dit je crains que
beaucoup d'enfants ne soit plus haut
niveau pour en faire et rose-marie qui
dit que
la dictée toujours sans apprendre les
règles de grammaire de conjugaison et
d'orthographe c'est stérile à voir ce
qu'on appelle des mois la fillette ans
et 20 aujourd'hui
donc je vois ce que l'on lui demande de
faire comme dictée on lui demande d'
apprendre des mots parker mais après
c'est pas grave si elle fait des fautes
sur autre chose
simplement il faut qu'elle est bon sur
les mots qu'elle a eu à prendre alors
utile ou pas utile ça pourquoi l'art et
ça pousse pas à l'intelligence et à la
réflexion
j'étais en train de me dire que corps il
faut pas faire ça mais en même temps je
veux la concurrence des deux sujets que
que qu'aurait pensé qu aurait pu dire
jean d'ormesson et il ya quand même un
paramètre g jean d'ormesson qui est une
sorte dans le disais tout à l'heure de
gai savoir enfin quelque chose de weeds
heureux de guerre voilà connaissant
l'école britannique et l'école française
les deux je peux comparer je peux vous
assurer que l'école française n'est pas
tellement dans le gai savoir c'est s'il
ya quelque chose toujours d'un petit peu
contre un sur wii et on n'est pas dans
n'est rarement dans la dans la gaieté de
l'apprentissage c'est ce n'est pas une
notion qui a tellement court et je pense
que c'est une lacune
alors je sais pas si nos internautes
sont dans le gai savoir ou pas en tout
cas ils sont plus de 94% à répondre à la
question du jour sur internet et à dire
qu'ils approuvent la mise en place d'une
dictée quotidienne à l'école vous
faisiez allusion aussi au fait au
dédoublement des classes de primaire ce
genre de mesure c'est coûteux marque
landrais pour l'éducation nationale
est-ce qu'on peut les multiplier comme
ça à l'infini ça dépend des tout est
question ici bien d'avoir des objectifs
encore faut-il en donner les moyens
ça dépend des moyens qu'on se donne pour
mon bien cet objectif vois la vie
autrement oui c'est coûteux sac ou de
plusieurs dizaines de millions d'euros
il faut il faut tout fera les locaux
pour pouvoir faire divisé par deux il
faut voir les profs quand même si après
il ya des rois il ya des redistributions
d'un niveau d'un niveau à l'autre mais
il n'empêche que c'est pas démultiplier
à l'infini
et même si on commence par les cp
l'année prochaine sera aussi n'est ce
pas ce qu'il faut suivre une cohorte
tout au long sur cette source continue
pour les cp mais on continue volé ces
maisons claires committee part 2 en
vérité donc oui mais ça dépend des
moyens qu'on se fixe pour l'instant il
ya un budget de l'éducation nationale
est en augmentation qui est prévue une
augmentation plus tôt significativement
mais c'est pas les seules priorités de
l'éducation que s'est fixé emmanuel
macron donc falloir faire des choix
alors c'est une autre question à ces
polémiques elle aussi la guerre des
crèches est elle relancée en principe
interdite crèche dans sa région auvergne
relate rhône alpes par le tribunal
administratif laurent wauquiez a décidé
d'y installer des santons descente on
lie pas vraiment puisqu'il s'agit d'une
scène de la nativité notamment est ce
une façon de contourner la décision du
conseil d'état qui a jugé que les
crèches n'ont pas leur place dans les
bâtiments publics au nom du principe de
neutralité sans doute mais laurent
wauquiez très peu probable futur
président des républicains parle-lui de
valorisation des savoir faire artisanaux
son principal soutien virginie calmels
ce était l'invité de rtl ce matin vous
vous allez voir elle est plus qu ashley
coûte laurent wauquiez a décidé cette
grande exposition culturelle pour faire
découvrir l'artisanat local de sa région
de l'ars et c'est au nom de rue c'est de
la politique artistique que le président
de la région installe des s'entend
vraiment c'est aussi parce que d'une
trame et on va arrêter de s'excuser
d'avoir des racines judéo chrétiennes
dans ce pays
moi je suis frappé de voir qu'on nous
ferait croire que la laïcité serait en
danger parce que il ya une croix sur une
statue de jean-paul 2 ou parce qu'à des
crèches dans des mairies ou dans des
conseils régional alors tradition
provocation je vous rappelle que vous
pouvez toujours vous prononcer via
twitter le figaro life figaro live ou
hashtag point de vue sur cette question
ivan rioufol laurent wauquiez il doit
respecter la loi
tout le monde doit respecter la loi mais
est ce que la loi est bien interpréter
ou pas dans les faits moi je suis de
ceux qui pensent que naturellement la
laïcité et quel état est un marqueur qui
doit être respecté mais est ce que la
laïcité à s'intéresser en effet à une
marque culturelle parce qu'on peut
considérer bien sûr que la crèche
aujourd'hui
une marque culturelle et dans le fond de
raisonnement dans le calme elle se tient
il a pu on n'y a pas ce n'est pas un
petit un petit enfant dans ce nom c'est
l'ange qui va mettre en péril la laïcité
française ils voient bien qu'il ya là
une incohérence et de faire ce
relativisme que j'entends maintenant de
dire oui mais si vous aussi vous si vous
autorisez les crèches
il faut autoriser le voile il faut
autoriser les prières dans la rue etc on
voit bien que le raisonnement il faussé
dès le départ car dans l'autre côté vous
avez en fait effectivement des prières
dans la rue pour reprendre cet exemple
là qui sont vraiment des affirmations
politique religieuse d'une identité et
d'une visibilité dans l'espace public et
de l'autre côté vous avez l'affirmation
d'une tradition qui se réveille dans les
faits il ne faut pas se cacher derrière
son petit doigt il y a derrière ces
initiatives
une manière de vouloir rappeler qu'ils
nous sommes mais je pense que cette
manière de vouloir rappeler notre
identité n'est pas fondamentalement
hostile à la laïcité d'autant que des
racines chrétiennes ont fourni le socle
de la laïcité au royaume n'est pas de ce
monde et donc moi je le suis de ce
depuis toujours qui pense qu'il aurait
été préférable en 2004 de d'inscrire les
racines chrétiennes de l'europe dans la
constitution européenne
cette constitution qui a d'ailleurs été
refusée par une partie des français on
peut s'imaginer que peut-être que cette
lacune on était une des raisons on ne
peut pas tout mettre sur le même plan
jean marc four comme le dit ivan rioufol
les prières de rue et je sens venir je
trouve ça terriblement français je
trouve que le les heures et les heures
et les heures à sans payet n'y a pas de
jeu de mots par rapport à la taille de
la crèche sur ces sujets de laïcité me
semble terriblement français je pars
dont j'ai envie de dire on n'a pas mieux
à faire
voilà donc ce que je non mais vous voyez
je vois bien que la laïcité aujourd'hui
est prise et plus en otage les prises en
otage par des groupes communautaires il
fut celui de savoir de quel type comment
on l'interprète mois ci c'est un film
que je vous invite à je vous invite
simplement à réfléchir à ça parce que je
m'intéresse à ce sujet savoir pourquoi
les mouvements islamistes se réclame
aujourd'hui de la laïcité alors que la
laïcité est en contradiction totale avec
avec ce qu'ils défendent et donc qu'ils
y trouvent leur compte dans une
interprétation ouvert très derrick st
clair c'est de la laïcité pas on a un
problème avec la laïcité déjà on la
connaît mal on croit que la laïcité
c'est la loi de 1905
le mot laïcité dans la 205 n'apparaît
pas il apparaît une fois dans la pré en
bulles
ses fans l'article premier de la
constitution basta ya pas de définition
n'a rien ensuite la laïcité c'est quoi
c'est un retour sur le concordat
car globalement met fin au concordat par
cette loi 1905 serre par l'affirmation
d'un principe laïc globalement on essaye
de trancher la question la séparation
entre l'état et la religion entre le
politique et le religieux
là on est sur une autre question qu'a
très bien décrite ivan rioufol unis sur
la dimension culture et c'est on a
besoin de quelque chose qui trace une
ligne entre le culturel et le cultuel
entre le religieux et la culture
c'est effectivement très français et
c'est ce qu'on disait de la révolution
française c'était aussi un petit
problème très français sauf qu'on a été
novateur je pense qu yves revol par la
révolution française la crèche jeu le
berger de l'enjeu non pas la prêche mais
par contre les questions qui émerge
aujourd'hui autour de la question de
l'islam de l'islamisme de l'islam
culturel de l'islam religieux du
christianisme avec un grand c ké
culturel avec un petit sac et religieux
ces questions là sont fondamentales
parce que les questions identitaires
fleurissent tout autour de la planète où
il ya une résurgence à la foi islamique
et chrétienne mais le sujet est
politiquement instrumentalisée dans tous
les sens
oui c'est à dire que je pense que quand
laurent wauquiez fait une flèche de 14
mètres carrés c'est à peu près la taille
de ce studio là où il l'a fait il sait
pertinemment que ça va déclencher le
mouvement que ça déclenche qu'il veut ça
va aller devant tribunal administratif
et le tribunal ne fatigue pas dire c'est
pas possible que le conseil d'état
derrière d'ailleurs c'est pas possible
parce que c'est comme ça après il a
commencé derrière d'ailleurs sur
suggestion sur suggestion du président
ps du conseil régional
vous me suivez il fait une exposition de
santons parce que c'est ça qui s'est
passé c'est le président ps du conseil
régional qui avant même que la crèche
soit installé lui avait dit mais il a
qu'a faire une exposition de santons non
mais si vous ratez sujet parce que
fondamentalement il n'a pas d'autre
moyen que de contraindre les pouvoirs
publics à faire émerger cette question
là pour qu'on s'en empare et pour chacun
mais dans tous les sens
oui mais voilà la loi n'évolue jamais
autrement que en la bousculant alors
pour le moment notre question twitter la
réponse entre tradition aux provocations
c'est à 54% nous internautes estiment
qu'ils ne sont pas provocation même
scoré assez serré on adhère
c'était pas une provocation mais c'est
de l'opportunisme politique pour bien
connaître laurent wauquiez s'est
absolument pas surprenants ce qu'il a
fait effectivement que vous disiez il
est il en est à trois semaines de
l'élection de la présidence de des
républicains il est ultra favori c'est
une élection qui n'intéresse personne
personne veut dire je mets ma main à
couper que les gens dans la rue sir
macnab le taux de participation à la
hune nombre de vols nombre de
participants à l'élection personne ne
connaît les candidats la mise à part
laurent wauquiez et encore et encore
donc c'est une manière habile
intelligente comme il est c'est
probablement l'un des mains des
politiques quel plus beau cv de la
république de faire parler de lui de
faire parler de cette idée de faire
l'idée clivante qui vantent pas dans son
camp mais qui vante par rapport à macron
puisque c'est l'ennemi qu'il s'est
identifiée par rapport à la
présidentielle de 2000 22
donc voilà pour moi c'est plus de
l'opportunisme politique que un débat
idéologique sur la place de la laïcité
dans la république ou pas et puis on va
c'est plus compliqué que cela répond
quand même aussi une irritation de
l'opinion que l'on voit poindre et qui a
été décrite si ça te monte de questions
identitaires c'est le rire mais avec la
croix et c'est avec cette irritation
face aux face au laxisme de l'état
devant les montées la montée en
puissance d'un islam politique qui a qui
affine sa visibilité dans l'espace
public à travers les les voiles les
prière les mosquées cathédrales etc on
voit bien que l'opinion commence à se
dire que il ya tout de même à deux poids
deux mesures qui se serait quand même la
moindre des choses que de la france qui
a mis 2 500 ans de l'histoire chrétienne
si on monte à clovis que la france
serait et aura même un endroit de
rappeler qu' et les voilà c'est aussi
simple que ça il et c'est un vrai
contrairement à vous je pense que c'est
un vrai débat de fond qui va poindre et
qui s'installe vraiment pas par une
équipe secrète avec des sans nom mais on
est en l1 là on est dans les cinq ans
avec notes on est dans les eaux et dans
l'anecdote on est d'accord mais enfin ça
passe par la nique de la lutte contre le
système politique passe pas
nécessairement par l'installation
bizarrement ça non mais là lui elle
passe par ce biais là maintenant c'est
passé par ce biais là que en effet c'est
par le biais de la licité que leur que
l'on dise que l'on distingue aujourd'hui
on commence à évoquer l'islam politique
que laurent wauquiez a voulu faire
émerger un vrai débat jean baptiste
émerger un faux nous avait rejoints
merci et je vais allez nous dire
effectivement ce qu'en pense la plupart
des internautes vrai débat ou
instrumentalisés
ça disons que ça va générer un vrai
débat effectivement et oppositions de
blocs matelas exactement opposition
d'internautes ceux qui sont vraiment
qu'ils disent que c'est bien et
soutiennent le président de région et
aussi ceux qui se moquent pas
spécialement qui sont contre mais qui se
moque j'ai d'abord un petit peu regardez
ce qu'ils sont plutôt positifs il ya
l'exemple d' arnold qui lui politise
carrément en voyant que c'est les partis
de gauche qui sont contre vos kaki vue
représentent les partis de droite
d'un autre côté stéphane lui félicite
carrément stephen wauquiez plx va
carrément voté pour laurent wauquiez
grâce à cette initiative pour lui c'est
du courage
guillaume y va avec un petit peu plus de
rire jaune dix ans guillaume lui propose
également qu'il faut ouvrir une boutique
éphémère pour vendre les santons et
ainsi renflouer les caisses de la région
mais le dit avec un vrai sérieux j'ai
pas l'impression qu'il dit ça en
rigolant mais je ne sais pas peut-être
que guillaume viendra nous expliquer un
peu plus son nez son état d'esprit des
sortants justement dont l'origine est
surtout provençal mais qui arrive à
l'hôtel de qui situe à lyon donc on nous
avons adele qui dit mort de rire donc
mdr c'est sur les santons de provence
sont une spécialité lyonnaise alors là
naturellement il rigole donc j'ai un
petit peu fait je suis parti à la
recherche des origines des santons oui
alors le jour en tout cas moi je me suis
instruit mais vous marier mes livres
saviez déjà que santon venait de cinq
ans tout en prenant salle est donc seul
ya plusieurs versions qui circulent sur
le web une des versions en tout cas et
que ça remonte à la révolution française
on parler de révolution française tout à
l'heure les églises avaient été fermés
mais il fallait que les gens à y
célébrer la messe
la messe de minuit et donc ils avaient
amené les statuts les seins chez eux
parce que thornton donc sain en
provençal veut dire petit st donc ils
ont ramené les petits seins chez eux
or la provence dépend du conseil
régional de provence alpes côte d'azur
qui est dirigée par le très républicain
renaud muselier et non laurent wauquiez
mais à ma connaissance n'a jamais eu
l'intention prennent l'exemple de robert
ménard beaucoup de robert maintenant
parce que lui il a mis sa crèche il a
maintenu sa crèche contre le conseil
d'état et d'ailleurs ils le montrent
bien sur twitter déjà un monde fou pour
voir la crèche de béziers impressionnant
se félicite il est enfin avec un peu
plus de légèreté julian lui prend
carrément laurent wauquiez pour un
artiste en mettant ceci n'est pas une
pipe ceci n'est pas une crèche c'est
vrai qu'une
une exposition de santons c'est un
certain côté surréaliste et alors je
voudrais merci beaucoup pour nous avoir
ainsi rappelé les origines des santons
je voudrais juste rappeler un autre
élément à votre réflexion
il ya eu cette information sur un
magasin d'épicerie à colombes laquelle
épicerie vend des produits strictement
halal
elle a été condamnée par le tribunal de
grande instance c'est l'office hlm qui
affecté qui loue les locaux allaient qui
serait en question et qui a dit non vous
ne pouvez pas vendre que des produits
halal et pas de vins fins pas d'alcool
ni deux ni de port donc là de poids
démesuré yvan je pense qu il faut lutter
contre le communautarisme est contre ce
séparatisme l'a des communautés qui
commencent à poindre équipe qui peut
poindre à travers ces magasins qui
hissent haut qui exclut par définition
ce qui ne veulent pas manger halal ou
qui veulent acheter du vin où je suis
donc il faut qu'il y ait au moins une
diversité dans ses magasins l'a donc
annoncé par deux poids deux mesures je
vois pas pourquoi vous mettriez en
comparaison et les crèches et vesa c'est
encore de ces encore 2 c'est à
relativiser c'est un relativisme qui ne
qui n'aide pas du tout à comprendre des
situations non je pense que en effet
héros se sont séparés peine de se cacher
à son petit doigt c'est vrai que la
société se fracture de plus en plus
s'oppose de plus en plus ce
communautarisme de plus en plus il faut
éviter naturellement cette dérive là
mais je pense que pour l'éviter il
faudrait au moins que la société
française s'affirme dans ce qu'elle est
sinon effectivement elle va pousser à
chaque fois les minorités à se croire
perd espoir permise de prendre le pas
sur sur la sur le bien commun si je suis
dit enfin sur leur la croix du christ de
ploërmel en bretagne qui surmonte la
statue de jean paul ii elle doit
déménager jean marc four oui enfin moi
je fais encore une fois je il ya des
décisions de justice et les décisions de
justice que voulez vous je vous
tribunaux sont là pour faire appliquer
la loi est votée par oui voilà etc voilà
il a effectivement ça remonte à la
séparation de l'état et le fait qu'on
avait plus depuis 19 ans semblait bon
sens et je pense que c'est à l'espace
molière mais encore une fois le mal que
j'ai dit et au début j'ai pas
fondamentalement changé d'avis je trouve
qu'on consomme beaucoup d'encre et
d'énergie sur ces sujets là et que je
serais bien mal aussi pertinent en
jamais cessé de réfléchir sur la sur la
loi c'est bien ça vient on peut pas
contester l'addition de justice elle se
fonde sur la loi la question c'est la
loi est ce que j'adore une garde
interprétation de conseil dans cette
décision une sorte d'incongruités
d'avoir que le conseil d'état autorise
malgré tout la statue de jean-paul ii
qui est quand même une halte aux
religieux mais qu'il qui lui a interdit
de porter son symbole qui est quand même
le symbole qui représente jean paul ii
donc ça ne veut pas dire cette
incohérence et ça ne veut rien dire la
lozère pour le coup la loi de 1905 dit
clairement mais en effet doivent être
supprimés alors voilà c'est vrai que
généralement littéralement en effet le
que le conseil d'état le conseil d'état
a fait une lecture littérale simplement
il a pu faire une interprétation de la
loi ce qui est autorisé aussi par le
conseil d'état et donc la ca donne une
imbécillité quoi on va faire plaisir à
jean marc four et passer un autre sujet
qui est assez lourd aussi celui de la
syrie et des activités de lafarge le
cimentier
il est entré ce dossier dans une phase
judiciaire avec la mise en examen de
trois cadres pour financement du
terrorisme
le scandale s'il y en a un c'est que
lafarge a continué à exploiter sa
cimenterie dans le nord de la syrie
entre 2012 et 2014 en pleine guerre
civile et surtout le groupe aurait versé
entre 80 et 100 mille dollars par mois
aux groupes terroristes qui contrôlaient
la zone
d'abord al qaïda puis ensuite l'état
islamique alors c'est un sujet qui
devrait vous fait réagir vous
internautes
lafarge en syrie pouvait-on ne pas
savoir je vous rappelle twitter le
hashtag figaro light hashtag point de
vue n'hésitez pas à donner votre avis
sur cette question
marc comment un groupe comme lafarge qui
n'est pas une obscure petite pme peut-il
agir ainsi je trouve que là la vraie
question c'est pourquoi on s'étonne
qu'ils aient agi ainsi c'est le seul
groupe dans la région qu'à continuer à
prospérer à
à faire du business sous domination de
dèche qui n'avaient pas qui jusqu'à
preuve du contraire était pas vraiment
un groupe porté vers le
multiculturalisme et qu'ils avaient
besoin voilà donc parce que franchement
tout autre groupe se sont arrêtés
lafarge a continué à faire du business
dans la région c'est forcément qu'il se
passait quelque chose
il y avait justement à l'évidence un
deal avec avec des jld est bien celui-là
vous mettez pourquoi personne ne s'en
est étonné parce que pai a pas grand
monde qui est allé dans la zone à
l'époque et qu'aujourd'hui ces sorties
et que effectivement on s'offusque du
fait qu'ils aient pu faire ces affaires
là avec des ch
mais je crois le vrai problème il est
pourquoi ils ont décidé de rester et un
parti dont ils ont décidé de rester ils
n'étaient ils étaient obligés de se
faire la loi de neige sur place et c'est
ça qui est choquant ce cadre
confidentiel
non c'était pas confidentiel mais encore
fallait-il aller sur place et savoir ce
qui s'y passe et j'ai dit franchement il
ya c'est quand même une zone qui tous
spécialistes du sujet maigreux grouille
un peu de services spéciaux et lafarge
personne n'a vu ce qui s'est passé ici
mais le temps que ça remonte le temps
que ça sorte est temps que la justice y
intéresse parce que il ya le temps le
temps de l'enquêté puis elle tourne la
justice si elle tend des remontées
d'informations des services généraux ou
des militaires sur place il a pris
haletant clé total par exemple avec
quitter la zone pas parmi les grands
groupes qui officie en syrie voilà
personne ne s'est étonné que lafarge
enfin jean-marc votre habitation sur
france inter on a consacré une grande
enquête à la fin j'ai un combat diffusé
à moi lafarge en syrie particulièrement
sur cette cimenterie qui est situé dans
la zone de jaca donc on est vraiment en
planant normalement là un territoire de
neige en plaine dans est il seulement
envisageable
un seul instant qu'une entreprise de la
taille de lafarge c'est le leader
mondial du secteur puissent maintenir
cette cimenterie dans des conditions
dont on ne sache au niveau des pouvoirs
publics que il ya quelque chose qui
relève du bakchich j'allais dire pas
seulement avec le groupe etat islamique
mais un peu avec tout le monde
enfin posé la question à mon avis c'est
y répondre et si on va et mais on peut
inverser le sujet pardon d'être
totalement cynique je vais être
totalement cynique je préviens d'avancé
le
autant que je puisse le savoir le
responsable de la sécurité du groupe
lafarge est quelqu'un qui connaît très
bien les services français c'est
quelqu'un qui a travaillé dans les
forces spéciales qui a travaillé dans
les commandos donc on est en droit de
penser que l'univers des services ne
vais pas un univers étrange et on peut
donc inversé de sujets c'est une
hypothèse mais elle n'est quand même pas
totalement farfelu c'est que c'était
aussi un moyen d'avoir une implantation
sur zone pour les services pour
surveiller les activités des groupes
terroristes
là vous renverser la perspective a alors
cessé complètement cynique parce que le
revers si je puis dire de cette
hypothèse c'est que malgré tout vous
financier dé facto le terrorisme avec
les conséquences que l'on sait donc
c'est extrêmement troublant mais c'est
quand même pas une hypothèse totalement
absurde vu ce qu'est la farge c'est pas
une pme dans un endroit qui fait son
truc parents souvent il faut la fait
trinquer les limpide l'élan fiscal est
encore un peu plus cynique que vous
aimez rappeler tout de même et nous
rappeler quelle était la position très
ambiguë de la diplomatie française à un
moment donné qui s'allier et non pas
avec des cheveux qui s'allie avec al
nostra qui est qui notamment était un
autre groupe de terroristes qui au
prétexte de vouloir faire la guerre à
machad mener une guerre une guerre
sainte si je puis dire et donc avec des
intérêts communs adech donc je moi je ne
connais pas le dossier
il ya naturellement scandaleux si
vraiment toute connaissance de cause
lafarge a payé un tribut à la dèche afin
de vendre son pétrole mais peut-être y
at-il en effet une sorte de de la part
des autorités françaises n'ont sinon de
connivence qu'on trouve en tout cas de
de flou artistique qui permettait de ne
pas trop comprendre quelle était la
politique française en tout cas moi je
ne l'avais pas comprise à l'époque c'est
en tout cas l'avis de nos internautes
qui répondent pour le moment à 80 % non
on pouvait pas ne pas savoir c'est aussi
votre avis frédéric saint clair oui
alors on va concourir ce soir pour le
poste du plus cynique je pense que j'ai
des chances d'emporter la palme je me
lance le capitalisme international ne
peut pas fonctionner autrement qu'en
calculant du risque pays c'est à dire en
se fichant finalement un peu de savoir
qui est gentil qui est le méchant il ya
une amoralité dans le capitalisme
intrinsèque
on est là pour survivre économiquement
et donc pour développer un business il
ya un risque pays s'est recueilli à pour
notre économie
une déstabilisation potentielle à cause
d'événements politiques était violent et
donc il faut il faut du bakchich hockey
jusqu'à là tout va bien on finance
aujourd'hui dahesh hier des moudjahidine
ok moralement ça change de camp on passe
du camp du bien au camp du mal au quai
au niveau du business et de la procédure
c'est la même donc moi je ne vois pas du
tout jusqu'à là qu'est ce qui coince
ensuite il ya au niveau comptable
comment est-ce qu'on masquer la chose
donc après on peut s'insurger sur les
éléments comptables et les faux
documents qui ont été fournis pour
cacher mais fondamentalement le coeur du
problème c'est quoi on a besoin de faire
tourner une entreprise est de rester le
leader mondial et donc on veut maintenir
ouverts parce que le risque pays n'est
pas suffisamment grand pour qu'on ferme
élément supplémentaire marc landré il y
avait la fusion peut enfin je ne sais
plus exactement entre lafarge et holcim
est ce que ça a pu rentrer en ligne de
compte
non mais ça on n'y rentre une compte
aujourd'hui puisque aujourd'hui
dirigeants du groupe sont des gringos
sont des hyènes d'holcim qui se retrouve
avec une casserole de lafarge le ménage
a été fait il va continuer à aller dans
l'assainissement peux pas imaginer que
certains chez holcim a franchement je
pleure en cédant au niveau de ceux qui
ont pris ces décisions là sur le terrain
n'était pas suffisamment connectés ou
suffisamment influents ou important pour
influer sur les décisions de négociation
de la fusion avec l'école sim
alors je peux être totalement bellahouel
très bête mais c'est juste
j'y crois pas je pense que c'est vous
savez j'aime aussi est surpris par ce
que disait emmanuel macron quand il est
allé en afrique on va me dire où tu
ramènes tout macron peut-être mais un
gros disais je n'ai pas à juger la
démocratie dans les pays dans lequel je
vais ils raisonnent pas la même façon
que moi il fonctionne pas la même façon
moi on peut faire un parallèle je veux
dire ce qui se passe soit derrière ou
des moudjahidine ce qui se passe
localement avec les coutumes les rites
les le business local
à un moment donné correspond à un état
des lieux de territoriales locales ont
le nous on le regarde depuis nos depuis
la france avec notre culture et sachant
ce qui s'est passé par la suite
notamment les attentes à 2015
je veux dire donc on a regardé y aurait
pas eu d'attentât 2015 peut-être qu'on
n'aurait pas le même regard porté sur ce
qui s'est passé à cette époque là une
hypocrisie on dit en finance le
terrorisme
littéralement sans mal an c'est la
qualification aurait il n'ya jamais
quelqu'un de lafarge qui s'est dit tiens
allons filer du pognon à des bluesmen
j'envoyais des bons moments en effet
pour ce match aura beau vous savez qui
figure au capital de cette cimenterie
assad
la famille assad figure dans les
personnes qui détiennent une partie du
capital de ces des sentry et entre en
zone état islamique
vous avez une idée de ce qu'est ce qu'on
disait tout à l'heure c'était ce paysage
ou fois les intérêts financiers
économiques
le calcul sur le coup d'après il faudra
reconstruire machin faut mettre des
bills à des bills adevia gauche de la
droite etc
voilà c'est ça un dernier mot l'image de
lafarge
elle en prend un coup mauvaise
d'ailleurs le nouveau patron le
reconnaît en termes de crédibilité ça
fragilise énormément et ça fragilise
d'autant plus les cadres venant de
lafarge puisque à défaut d'avoir une
responsabilité pénale tout ce qu'ils ont
au moins une responsabilité morale
indéniable bien merci beaucoup à tous
les quatre on se retrouve demain pour un
nouveau point de vue et ne manquez pas
le figaro avec onze pages spéciales sur
jean d'ormesson onge page spéciale avec
une manchette s'appelle au revoir et
merci avec une très belle photo de
l'écrivain merci à tous de nous avoir
suivi
[Musique]